now would we not be able to say anything
about uh marvel john bishop presumably
that sounds familiar because you've now
joined the world of doctor who
i have i have that's that can you tell
us my
lockdown experience yeah we've only seen
your face
yeah at the end of the new year's
episode yeah yeah it's saying so i'm the
new companion to the doctor
uh i'm allowed to say that yeah i'm
allowed to say that
but that's about it i did i did the
thing
for some drama students in liverpool and
you know a big zoom thing
and uh and it was a q a it was just
talking about acting and how you get
into it or you get into stand-up comedy
and then and then one of the questions
was can you tell us anything about your
character
in doctor who uh you know where does he
come from
i went well where do you think he comes
from here
i have a guess well i mean like i'm not
tom cruise i can act as long as the
character happens to look and sound a
lot like me
so so it just meant that the character
was from liverpool
which then somewhere on a doctor who
website someone picked her up there's a
new character he's from liverpool the
story is based in liverpool that becomes
so
then the bbc followed me up and said
you've broke the cardinals in you've
told them something about doctor who
when i went
i haven't told them anything anybody who
looks at me and knows he's from
liverpool
to be honest
[Music]